let's try to evaluate the indefinite
integral 1 over the square root of 1
minus x squared DX and you might try
something like u substitution but you'll
find out that it doesn't get you very
far with this integral and so instead we
will do something called trig
substitution and the whole idea of
buying trigonometric substitution is to
substitute for X so that with a with a
trig function so that this might
simplify using some trig identities and
maybe it'll turn this entire integral
into something that we can actually
integrate and so the trig substitution
that we'll do and the the big clue here
is when we see this 1 minus x squared
and in fact if we ever see an a squared
minus an x squared so 1 is 1 squared
minus x squared it's a pretty good clue
that we would want to substitute with
something times sine of theta in this
case if we just make the substitution if
we say that X is equal to let me do it
over here X is equal to if we say that X
is equal to sine of theta then what we
have under the radical right over here
is going to become 1 minus sine squared
theta which is cosine squared theta and
then we could take the square root of
that and that might simplify all of this
business a good bit and we just want to
make sure that we're not artificially
constraining our X more than what the
domain here would otherwise constrain
our X so if you look over here the X
cannot be the X right over here has to
be less enmet has to have an absolute
value less than 1 or another way of
saying it the domain right over here X
has to be greater than negative 1 and
less than and less than positive 1 if it
was 1 then the denominator right here is
going to be 0 if it was greater than 1
or less than negative 1 then all of a
sudden you're going to have a negative
under the radical sign
so already our domain is constrained for
these values of X so if we say X is sine
theta this is actually allows X to be
anywhere between negative 1 and 1
including negative 1 and 1 so we're not
constraining X more than the domain has
already constrained it since we're going
to have to unwind the substitution later
on let's also define theta in terms of X
so let's say and in a way that's not
consistent with this
top statement so let's also say that
theta is equal to arcsin or inverse sine
of X and what does this do well this
actually constrains what our theta is
going to be if I draw a unit circle if I
draw a unit circle my best to draw one
so this is my unit circle and if I come
up with if I come up with a particular
if I come up with a particular X that's
going to be essentially the potential
signed value arc sine is going to give
an angle that isn't even is is in the
first or fourth quadrant so if we say
that this is our sine if this is our X
then the arc sine of X is going to be
this angle not this one out here in the
second quadrant if we say that this is
our X and our arc sine is going to be
our arc sine is going to be this angle
so this right over here constrains
constrains theta to be less than or
equal to PI over two so less than or
equal to that and greater than or equal
to negative PI over two this is the way
the arc sine function is typically
defined it will return a value between
negative PI over 2 and PI over 2 or
another way of saying that in this range
right over here on the unit circle and
this will be important later on when we
try to simplify this expression let's
actually try to simplify it now before
we do that so we could substitute we
could substitute X but we're also gonna
have to substitute for DX so let's
figure out what DX is equal to DX is
equal to well the derivative of sine
theta with respect to theta is cosine
theta D theta so now we're ready to
actually evaluate or at least simplify
so our original integral becomes the
integral of 1 times DX well DX is cosine
theta D theta cosine theta I'll put the
D theta out here over over the square
root over the square root of 1 minus x
squared which is now going to be 1 minus
sine squared theta well what is 1 minus
sine squared theta well that's going to
be cosine theta or cosine squared theta
let me write this down one minus sine
squared theta is equal to cosine squared
theta this comes straight out of the
unit circle definition of trig functions
cosine squared plus sine squared is
equal to one so we can rewrite this as
being equal to and the indefinite
integral of cosine theta D theta
over over the square root of cosine
squared theta now we have to be a little
bit careful here we have to think about
whether cosine theta is going to be
either positive or negative or maybe we
don't know if we square a number then
take its principal root we're
essentially taking the absolute value of
it if cosine of theta was say negative
one and we squared and then take the
principal root it will get one if the
cosine theta was positive one that we
still get one so right now all we can do
without knowing more information about
cosine of theta is say this could be
re-written as cosine theta over the
absolute value of cosine theta over the
absolute value of cosine theta if you
square something and then take the
positive square root the principal
square root you're essentially just
taking its absolute value and so it's
really tempting to simplify this more
but we can't quite do it without
understanding what cosine of theta is
going to be equal to well lucky for us
we've already constrained theta to be
equal to arc sine of X and so that says
that theta is going to be between
negative PI over two and PI over two and
in this range of Thetas we're always in
kind of the positive x-axis so cosine of
theta which is the x-coordinate for
whatever wherever we sit on the wherever
we sit on the unit circle is always
going to be positive and since cosine of
theta so let me make this clear arc sine
of theta is equal to arc sine of X tells
us that cosine of theta is going to be
greater than or equal to zero it's going
to be non-negative I guess is the best
way to say it not necessarily positive
it could still it could still be it
could still be equal it could still be
equal to zero so it's going to be
non-negative and since it's not negative
the absolute value of a non-negative
number is just the number itself so this
is just going to be equal to the
integral and I'll just do it in one
color of cosine theta over cosine theta
D theta which is just equal to the
integral of D
theta which is equal to theta plus C and
now all we have to do is unwind this
substitution we already know that theta
is equal to arcsin of X so we could say
this is equal to arcsin arc sine X plus
C and we're done using trig substitution
we were able to evaluate this indefinite
integral and another way you could think
about is we've out we've just figured
out what the derivative of arc sine of
arc sine of X is by taking the
antiderivative of this
we got arc sine of X plus C if we take
the derivative of arc sine of X we get
this business right over here